[Music]
w w w k ng the Dutch station
greetings [__] uncle Joey a pilot
to Bombardier Wednesday December 7th you
know what that means 24 hours more for C
so to release uncle Joey's first
stand-up [__] special you understand
me I'm very excited but I'm more excited
for you [__] cuz you got my
back and at the end of the day when you
got somebody's back and they move a
little forward that means you're about
to move [__] forward if you're
cheering for me you're gonna move
forward concept him you're sitting there
gonna [__] this fat [__] felon
then you're gonna fail too that's the
way that you gotta be happy for people I
didn't know that either for years I
would sit and put the Maluku on people
and then you see your life falling apart
it's because you're putting them a look
on people can't put them a look on
people trust me
I still put them a look on these
[__] from time to time cuz
they're confused but you can't do that
but enough with that [__] the time
to get down is the man of many reefers
we got this one will perennial this is
the ship perennial got in the back
that's killing [__] you
understand me
so that's the word they don't put them a
book on somebody you feel [__] up
about something hey I hear a lot of
[__] you just don't say no but
their seat be there and put them a look
that's completely different you only my
look you should be putting on people's
this right here this [__] reefer blow
smoke in their face and they'll hire
like me now [__]
I got a big day today out here the
guards are good evil
alright rainy all morning then I got
Rogan at lunchtime so the jie three
o'clock eastern time twelve o'clock
lunch time [__] then I got some [__]
at 4:00 I got a big day today no commie
this week tomorrow me and Luis Gomez
from [__] skank fest and many other
[__] things I love that [__]
we're going deep tomorrow night you
understand women having adopt around
staff charge me like [__] 100 an hour
[__] Michael Jackson had doctor to
marry I gotta show up with some
[__] it and make sure we don't
die
take cloud your app nobody gives a [__]
except you you gotta go out there making
[__] difference three you got to show
these concept you just not some [__]
bump on the Bob I'm saying you're
slinging dick and giving our birthdays
let's try this [__] cake will leave
this big [__] elimedia
pushes [__] tremendous here
BAM boom here we are we I'm saying this
is the best when we get together in the
morning this this is the best [__]
right we have as in marriages we push a
button we smoke dope and wit together
the energies the minds the hearts the
souls they're all together then you go
on and you [__] there this is genius
II you know just the opportunity for us
to get together in the morning
this is [__] tremendous it's a [__]
who gives ition who's president he ain't
stopping Barris no bitch-ass nice my
lung is [__] on fire for being savages
nobody's being on point with yong-chol
Joey you got my back I got your back
like I tell you [__] I'm with
you you're with me and they're with us
okay who gets the [__]
they'd go nice and beside that that's it
that's that it's that easy
you got your goals you got a job to do
Oh little something for the [__] bad
wolf [__] fruit smoothie this morning
and it's starting to come out of my
little muffler here how to kill a
[__] squirrel over he ever had my
uncle's fruit smoothies for breakfast
some [__] cherries strawberries some
blueberries couple ice cubes takes your
[__] stomach I got a I fought it
before I was [__] tremendous but
anyway beside that we got each other
and you got today and that's the most
important did we smoke this much well I
might just stuff in stone put it over my
god [__] [__] except in the morning
already here we go
anyway I'll see you [__]
lunchtime on the JRE and don't forget
tonight at midnight it all goes down see
so TV code name Joey you get two months
for free all right man I love you
[__] you know I'm trying here
beside that you got the world by the
balls really looking at me forward a
stupid [__] looking at your face
walked into some we think that this was
all [__] a fairy tales from either
people knocked on your door with another
dollar bill wagon they don't you gotta
get on top of the honey all built wagon
but before you know it you know the
dollar machine then you gotta get on a
flight out machine then you get on the
ten dollar machine then you gotta pull a
gun then you're on the Halal [__]
machine so that's how we're doing it
today on the [__] Wednesday December
7 car service
because I love you that's why that's how
you start off a [__] when everybody
wakes up on her Wednesday I don't feel
good my face might not listen get up
your [__] will give us a [__] about your
feet just bought [__] Cuban swam 90
miles you worried about your [__]
feet you ever take it that when I need
my hours shark-infested waters I don't
have with you [__] have on a
daily so every time you don't want to do
something think about those
[__] on a raft looking around
getting suntan with no SPF on that put
your shoes on
brush your [__] teach people some
wool some water in your [__] [__]
and get out there they're not gonna give
it to you but guess what you could take
it cause it's Briggs name even if you
gave up they still couldn't win you ever
think of that
even if you give up finish they still
can't win that's how big your [__]
dick in your soul is [__] so
get out there I'll see you [__]
at lunch time this [__] my fancy I know
Lonnie I gotta take two steps from the
rear and get out of here that fruit
smoothie went right through uncle Joey I
did the do Doug Benson show the high
court [__] kudos to Doug Benson for
calling me and then let me smoke reefers
[__] I was getting anxiety but that's it
that's now see you cops up it's at lunch
time make sure you there I love you have
a great day don't forget code Joey and
you get two months for free stay black
[__]